BUYLEESA.COM TODAY. YOU NEED
THIS BED.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THE 2008 FINANCIAL
COLLAPSE WAS HUGE AND COMPLEX.
ITS CAUSES ARE MANY, BAD RISK
MODELS, BAD GOVERNMENT POLICIES
FOR SURE, BAD BUSINESS
DECISIONS, PROBABLY OTHER THINGS
TOO.
SPEAKING ON A PANEL OF FEMINISTS
YESTERDAY, SENATE NONENTITY
KRISTEN GILLIBRAND IDENTIFIED
ANOTHER BECAUSE YOU PROBABLY
HADN'T EVEN THOUGHT OF, GENDER.
MEN ARE THE PROBLEM SHE SAID.
HERE'S WHAT SHE SAID ABOUT THE
COLLAPSE OF THE INVESTMENT BANK
LEHMAN BROTHERS.
WATCH.
>> THAT'S WHY THE EMPOWERMENT OF
WOMEN IS SO IMPORTANT THROUGHOUT
THE ECONOMY AND THROUGH
LEADERSHIP IN HIS OFFICE IS
BECAUSE WE DON'T VALUE WOMEN IN
SOCIETY AND THAT'S JUST A FACT.
IF IT WASN'T LEHMAN BROTHERS BUT
LEHMAN SISTERS WE MIGHT NOT HAVE
HAD THE FINANCIAL COLLAPSE.
>> Tucker: TAMMY BRUCE IS A
RADIO HOST AND PRESIDENT OF
INDEPENDENCE WOMEN'S VOICE AND
SHE JOINS US TONIGHT.
I FEEL ALMOST MEAN IN PLAYING
THAT.
I DON'T DISLIKE KRISTEN
GILLIBRAND.
I FELT SORRY FOR HER WATCHING IT
BECAUSE IT DIDN'T MAKE ANY
SENSE, IT WAS KIND OF SAD, BUT I
THOUGHT MAYBE THERE'S SOMETHING
DEEPER HERE AND SINCE YOU ARE
OUR RESIDENT DEEP PERSON I
THOUGHT I WOULD RUN IT BY YOU.
WHAT YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> I CAN GET AS DEEP AS JUST
SAYING IT WAS STUPID.
IT'S INSULTING, IT IS SEXIST AND
IT'S AN ARGUMENT THAT
MISOGYNISTS MAKE.
WHAT SHE WAS REFERRING TO IS A
STUDY THAT SAID BECAUSE WOMEN
ARE RISK-A VERSE, THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE TAKEN LESS CHANCES
AND SO LEHMAN BROTHERS WOULD
HAVE BEEN JUST FINE.
THIS ARGUMENT THOUGH PUTS ALL
WOMEN INTO A CATEGORY OF
EXPECTING THEIR BEHAVIOR TO BE
BASED ON THEIR GENDER.
AND IT IS GENDER STEREOTYPICAL.
IT IS BASED IN A SEXIST
EXPECTATION THAT WOMEN ARE GOING
TO BEHAVE A CERTAIN WAY BECAUSE
OF THEIR SEX, AND THIS IS THE
OTHER ARGUMENT THAT MISOGYNIST
HE WAS, THAT WOMEN ARE
RISK-AVERSE AND AS A RESULT THEY
ARE MORE FRIGHTENED BY THINGS, T
ARE MORE FRIGHTENED BY THINGS, E
ARE MORE FRIGHTENED BY THINGS, Y
ARE MORE FRIGHTENED BY THINGS, A
ARE MORE FRIGHTENED BY THINGS, E
ARE MORE FRIGHTENED BY THINGS, L
ARE MORE FRIGHTENED BY THINGS, S
ARE MORE FRIGHTENED BY THINGS, A
ARE MORE FRIGHTENED BY THINGS, T
ARE MORE FRIGHTENED BY THINGS, O
TAKE RISKS.
--   WOMEN'S LIVES ARE FILLED I
--   WOMEN'S LIVES ARE FILLED H
RISK.
WE GIVE BIRTH TO CHILDREN, IT'S
RISKY.
WE CHANGE THE ACADEMY, WE CHANGE
THE MILITARY.
EVERYTHING WE DO EVERY DAY IS A
RISK AND WE DO IT WELL.
BUT THE ARGUMENTS BY MISOGYNISTS
ARE THAT BY PINNING ALL WOMEN
TOGETHER THROUGH THEIR GENDER IS
WHY WOMEN DON'T MAKE HISTORY.
IF THAT WOMEN ARE NOT BRAVE
ENOUGH TO DO GREAT ART.
THAT WE AREN'T INTERESTING
ENOUGH TO INVENT THINGS.
THAT WE ARE NOT BRAVE ENOUGH TO
BE MILITARY LEADERS.
SHE'S ARGUING THERE THROUGH THIS
RISK-AVERSE GENDER-BASED
STEREOTYPE THAT A WOMAN COULD
ALSO NOT BE A PRESIDENT BECAUSE
IT'S THE SAME FRAMEWORK.
AND THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE TO
REJECT AND SO OF COURSE IT'S
INSULTING AND IT IS MISOGYNIST
AND SEXIST TO BOOT.
>> Tucker: I GUESS I'M LOOKING
AT IT FROM THE OTHER ANGLE,
WHICH IS WHY IS SHE ATTACKING
MAN?
I'M A MAN.
I HAVE A SON WHO WAS AN ADULT
MAN.
HE DIDN'T DO ANYTHING TO TANK
THE BANKS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
PROFIT FROM CREDIT DEFAULT
SWAPS.
WHY ARE YOU BLAMING A HUGE GROUP
FOR THE SINS OF A FEW?
>> BECAUSE IT'S WHAT YOU'VE
RECOGNIZED REPEATEDLY AND I
THINK EXCLUSIVELY.
IF THIS ARGUMENT BY THE LEFT
ABOUT TOXIC MASCULINITY.
IT IS ABOUT CONDEMNING AND
INDICTING ALL MEN FOR SIMPLY
BEING MEN.
AND HER ARGUMENT IN ORDER TO
COUNTER THAT, YOU CAN'T ARGUE
WHAT WENT FEMINISTS -- AT LEAST
MY GENERATION DID, THAT WOMEN
CAN DO WHAT MEN DO.
WE IN FACT ARE VERY SIMILAR.
OUR STYLES MIGHT BE MORE
DIFFERENT BUT WOMEN CAN
ACCOMPLISH WHAT MEN CAN
ACCOMPLISH.
WHAT SHE'S ARGUING IS THERE'S
TOXIC MASCULINITY AND THAT IS A
FOUNDATIONAL THEORY NOW OF THE
LEFT.
WE HAVE TO COUNTERACT IT BY
SAYING THAT THE PEACEFUL, SIMPLE
WOMAN WHO IS NOT AS AGGRESSIVE
IS THE ANSWER.
THIS NOW CONDEMNS THEM INTO
PUTTING WOMEN INTO ONE CATEGORY
IN ORDER TO SUCCEED AT
CONDEMNING ALL MEN, AND WHAT
THEY END UP DOING IS SAYING THAT
WOMEN CAN'T BE PRESIDENT, WOMEN
CAN'T BE A LEADER, -- WELL,
LOOK, WE HAD ONE PRESIDENT WHO
BEHAVE THIS WAY AND IT WAS
BARACK OBAMA.
A MAN WHO WAS TOO AFRAID TO
CONFRONT ISIS, TOO AFRAID OF HIS
OWN REDLINE WITH SYRIA.
TOO AFRAID TO REALLY GOVERN AND
HELP THE ECONOMY.
TOO AFRAID TO MAKE CHANGE AROUND
THE WORLD.
THAT'S WHAT SHE'S ADVOCATING FOR
AND IT CERTAINLY IS NOT A
FEMININE TRAIT.
>> Tucker: I DON'T BLAME ALL
WOMEN FOR KRISTEN GILLIBRAND.